in the Oprah interview you accuse
members of your family of racism you
don't even well of the British press
said that did Megan ever mention the
races she said there were troubling
comments about what she was concern
about his skin color right wouldn't you
describe that as essentially I wasn't
not having lived within that family
neither of us believe that that comment
or that experience
or that opinion was based in racism my
God the irony of this
from a man who's literally just produced
these single most self-justifying
centering self-centering version of
events imaginable then you have someone
like Prince Harry who's worth you know
he's got to be worth 60 million you know
they say around 60 million but like it's
just an endless amount of wealth and he
runs around Western media sobbing about
his family and his circumstances and the
racism he comes from and how terrible
the hierarchy of the of the family is in
all of these things